tomorrow good afternoon how can dr d
and i help thank you so much
um i'm a little nervous and i ramble so
please directing if needed um so
a little background my husband and i
have been married about six and a half
years
we have a beautiful little boy and a
little girl on the way in january
congrats thanks
um we both did undergraduate completely
debt-free
with grants and scholarships and little
measly 20-hour week jobs
um it was really fun and now we're
actually
my husband's in his third year of
medical school and we're still debt-free
because he was able
we were very blessed to get a
scholarship um
wow that's pretty cool yeah
it's um god has really been good to us
and um you know even though we've got
this scholarship
our entire marriage we've been living
beneath the poverty line
we've never had debt we've always been
able to pay tithing
always been able to be generous and
always been able to save a little
um and um and even
by the time we move out to residency we
should have
a good down payment for a house so i
mean it's
um so that's that's me and my husband
um so how can we help
you get emotional um
so my parents
i'm really i'm really worried for them
they make um about 200 000
a year which is about i make about 10 of
that
and it's just hard because i've been
able to make that work
um and my parents
rival congress like they just can't seem
to make it work
and um
in the past two or three weird years um
things have gotten really weird because
of
like i'm guessing because of money um
but like just for an example
um this year when i found out i was
pregnant
um i wanted to go stay with my parents
for a little while
i paid for my plane ticket and
um while i was out there my grandma
we were told she was she had 72 hours to
live
and so my dad was going to pay for the
ticket and he's like i don't have enough
money in the bank so i just
paid for the emergency flight
um which was really hard for us but we
did it and i'm glad we did
but then i was asking them hey you know
because of
my husband's rotations um and because
of my pregnancy i didn't feel like we
should travel for thanksgiving this year
so i said can you come out here
and the response was just
oh i don't know if we can afford it so i
don't know if we can afford it
so is your is your frustration or
concern that
um you you think that
you know that they make a lot of money
yet they don't seem like they've got
money
to spend it the way that you think they
should be spending it
um i mean i guess that's a little bit of
it
i intentionally asked that in a in a
confrontational way by the way
um right and i guess what i'm getting at
is this
um your parents
make their money and they can spend it
how they want to spend it
and it can be really frustrating
when you are have a set of values that's
different from your loved ones
when you have a set of values that you
are making things work you are
scratching and
clawing and biting and fighting on
below the poverty line and you're not
borrowing money
you're you're helping your husband get
through med school
which is a like traumatic endeavor in
itself
and your parents don't share those same
values
and so it hurts when you think
somebody's got a lot of money and they
say
i don't have enough money to come visit
you because that sounds like a value
judgment that sounds like
oh if you were making better decisions
then you would be able to come spend
time with us
and you're not right and really through
the day this is a harsh statement but i
want you to put in your heart and soul
you don't get a vote and how they spend
their money you don't get a vote
in their financial dysfunction
and you will get a vote when it comes to
what how home they're going to be put in
right um and they don't have
any money in savings you'll get a vote
then but what i want to challenge you
is to take that poison out of your heart
set it down
because all you're doing is it's it's
it's poisoning and flavoring and
coloring every phone call you have with
them
every interaction you have with them and
it's just got this heated season that's
unnecessary
you love your parents they make
different life choices in you
you really disagree with their values
when it comes to how they spend their
money how they make their money
but don't carry that poison around with
you or say your values are so different
than mine i'm cutting you off
if i'm not worth having a budget and
you're um
you know your daughter and your
son-in-law aren't worth visiting because
you won't do a budget
um tell them that and then say when you
decide to get right with
your souls in in your budget then so be
it
that'd be foolish that'd be silly but
you're welcome to do that right
that'd be dumb um don't do that tomorrow
anthony's the voice of reason just uh
don't whatever you just said yeah but
i i agree i agree tomorrow with with
with what john is saying you don't get a
vote now here's where here's what you do
get
you do have the right to say something
once you say something then leave it
alone
okay um i've had several of those
conversations with both sets of my
families you know i have two biological
parents and two by
two step parents and technically all
four of them are my parents i hate the
term step parents
and and both of them you know i
because i'm in a money space i'm like yo
y'all can make a little better decision
than that
why did you go do that don't do that but
then i had to quickly realize okay
um that's my opinion that's my life i
can't force it on to them
i i give them my advice after that i'm
not going to stress
myself and if i was married i'm
definitely not losing
sleep i'm not getting emotional because
my parents are grown people
and i got a spouse and kids here and you
know you're you have a husband
you have a family listen tomorrow make
sure
that you and your husband do not become
your parents that's your number one
concern right now
make sure that your kids can look up to
you
as making the right decisions
financially make sure that you are
living
by an example that you are the example
that you want your kids to model
you know love your parents give them
guidance give them
freedom but you know what at the same
time worried about your
worry about your family i wouldn't worry
about your mom and dad right now
get up give them your thoughts give them
your prayers
and move on put it down